uh
[Music]
you will be the greatest man of all time
[Music]
federal law prohibits filming of
endangered falcons except for
educational purposes
to avoid federal crimes and maximum
penalty of up to five years in prison
the following comedy sketch has been
edited in post-production to be
educational viewer discretion is advised
the hell are you doing
this is our falcon crowdershop.com
mascot i'm gonna teach her how to
hunt and you can you don't think about
falconing
actually it's falconry which
historically was a popular sport and
status symbol among
the nobles of medieval europe and japan
where it's called takaguri
falconry has been around forever and may
have even been started in mesopotamia
[Music]
it's kind of
look you've got a hysterical little
helmet with a
spear
good question steven the falcons hood
used during the phase of its acclimating
to humans which is referred to as the
manning process
is used to keep the raptor
in a calm state both in early parts of
its training and throughout his life
[Music]
you think we could get it to attack
brandon
[Music]
do you want to attack brendan
yes
[Music]
falcons aren't naturally human
aggressive orchestra will do well
starting with
chicken hearts livers then switching to
other meats like sparrows other small
birds
ducks
ducks and pigeons
uh
then they move on to mice and insects so
remember if you see a falcon in the wild
it's more afraid of you
than you are of him
to her but
falcons yeah be badass but not as badass
as merchandise which you can get at
crowdershop.com
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
hmm
that is a delicious covered free sip
negative again yesterday i'm sorry for
the kovid so uh which really sucks
because i'm actually sick
i'm done with it everyone in my family
everyone got the covet they're all fine
i repeat myself and uh i just have a
sinus infection so i apologize for the
sound some people have actually been
sending me emails oh really saying don't
sniff in the microphone
well i'll consider it
no you won't no there's nothing i can do
about it uh we have a lot to get to
today there's a lot going on
not not a lot that's really important
this is one of those days when you look
in the media and you see them trying to
make them you know some people have used
the term mountain out of a molehill yeah
because uh mountains are typically
they're much larger than mole hills
what's a molehill i've never seen a mole
uh it's a hill made by i could have just
been inaccurate as far as i don't know
do we even just to scale molehill i'm
not sure we'll look into it i have some
prairie dogs do you have some pretty ah
well you did just drink two uh two rock
stars so uh what are we talking about
the military we're gonna be talking
about the canadian prime minister who
loves blackface i love i wish i loved
anything as much as he loves blackface
blackface and how woke the military is
as well as the uh the fbi sting
operation yeah the glow stick operation
that happened in
washington dc this weekend we're going
to cover how the media covered it versus
what actually happened yeah unbelievable
uh and it's amazing if you watch cnn
this morning the way they tried to cover
this with a straight face you could see
that these people like i just give me my
retainer and send me on my way all right
we have gerald a is here how are you sir
i'm well how are you i'm doing well all
right i'm doing okay you're the kind of
sick we don't care about anymore yeah no
one cares about this not really no you
don't have covert uh next no no no i've
uh and i was talking about this uh i'll
talk about it afterwards it's a you know
bridging the racial divide with black
people how are you speaking of which
you're doing good yeah yeah uh guten
morgan yeah just playing to the base i
don't know what that means no sickle
cell no not anymore no somebody called
again
and uh dave landa how are you ahoy
i'm delicious that was a little bit of a
delay he hurt his neck just so you know
i did i what did you do i sat in a plane
oh well that'll do it sometimes that'll
do it i'm at that age where i dozed off
on a plane improperly in a neck pillow
and i woke up like i'd been wrestling
david no we're wrestling blacked out
again dave no i wish i wish i could
explain it like that i don't know woke
up in my driveway
you were missing your pants as well come
on be honest well i wasn't missing them
i just wasn't wearing them he doesn't
you don't yearn for them not a pants guy
no one's a pants guy i like to daffy
duck or donald duck when i'm on an
airplane
wear a shirt nothing
i'm a else
winnie the pooh when it comes to flying
speaking of honey pots um
thank you oh bother uh
oh wait is your is your neighbor on the
plane kevin smith taking up two seats
just yes
did they have lando not wearing pants
i don't know what's going on he's a fats
on a [ __ ] so uh what day is he dead no
he lost no way
that's right
he looks like he looks like uh someone
stuffed
a bag of kevin smith
with someone to resemble kevin's yeah he
looks like a guy who should be fat yes
and i don't like when people who should
be fat lose weight because you're like
well now you just look weird right yeah
like star jones yeah it's like come on
you know you were you know you were star
joe now you look like a ladybug who
sneezed yeah also you're a millionaire
maybe get jerseys that fit yes
or maybe just don't wear jerseys i don't
know so we we do have a lot and we'll
also be talking about uh the marvel
movie which i don't care about shenshi
that was called shang chang
okay oh wow
but first uh the left on uh on tick tock
now this is the new thing and gerald
will be happy to hear about this they've
been uh claiming that jesus uh the son
of god we can get in the whole trinity
thing i don't wanna get theological
because this is tick-tock
that jesus
christ uh is non-binary here you go
this is an easy one if you espouse to
the idea that jesus was born of a virgin
birth then jesus could not have had male
chromosomes therefore jesus
had only female chromosomes just to
argue
and present it as masculine
so
jesus was non-binary and in terms of
male and female and the hebrew the word
that was used for and
describes a spectrum
male and female and everything in
between
man and woman is a biological concept
science currently identifies 13
combinations and permutations of xy
chromosomes masculine and feminine is a
sociological construct that is dependent
upon the society with which you are
talking about
um
ah wrong yeah very important first off
if you're talking about god man but if
we're talking about jesus christ
certainly a man
yeah and i don't know what that was
so the which permutation are you
one that we need to get rid of sorry not
not physically but just you know no the
one that creates jerry curls and a king
tut beard
that's what you meet in hell
you're like you can have a conversation
with this guy or you're getting raped by
a spider yeah you're like yeah
i'll talk to the spider for a minute and
see
i'll talk to the one who looks like a
yule brenner prosthetic by the river
styx what were you about to say there
gerald say that look this does get into
a little bit of theology but if you're
if you if you presuppose a virgin birth
why would you limit anything that
happens after that
of course he could have had male
chromosomes god could have been like
boom male chromosomes done yeah like why
would you think that that is the best
place to jump off from in this
conversation that's idiotic well the
thing is too here this is something that
a lot they do lgbtq aip um and they talk
about permutations these are incredibly
rare yeah let's also be really clear
like if you're talking about someone
who's intersex or klein filters they
usually identify as a significant uh
they have a significant
amount of secondary sex characteristics
that make it clear as to what they
actually are and these people want to
act like because you know they started
taking estrogen artificially right that
uh well i'm part of that intersex they
don't want to be associated with you and
uh nor by the way does the son of man
well
son
son or children at the pool god i don't
know maybe it's in the name i don't know
maybe you look there now by the way
you're wrong on the hebrew too
man and female means both it means the
human species okay that's what he's
trying to talk about it's not trying to
talk about man or woman it's talking
about both what's the hebrew word for um
gamora okay
it's just which uh also the synonym for
pillar of salt yeah okay yeah
yeah i don't think jesus was big into
estrogen no i'm not known i don't
remember he was like you know what i
need up and i cross some fake tits
that'll make it easier i'm just trying
to be let his blood be uh beyond the
descendants of our z z z's
so
and uh the x and the y wait wait wait
wait there's there's z's after oh no
we're yeah we have no idea you're on the
wrong team he's the son of whatever this
is just this is where we are
this is the issues is the subversion of
language and look people will talk we're
going to get into the vaccination chris
rock has uh vaccinated and just got
covered in the statistics there just so
you know and this is something we don't
need to worry about anymore on youtube
because if we'd have said this three
weeks ago
be in trouble uh if you're vaccinated
there's still a good chance you can get
covet just so you know now it's okay we
used to say there are no breakthrough
cases right no it's actually it's it's
the rule now it's not the exact sciences
maybe you won't be hospitalized maybe
there's protective effects sure but if
you think the vaccine protected you
that's not true but uh back to uh
godless heathens um culturally this
matters more at a certain point where
they're really they're tr they will call
evil good and good evil i mean i just
noticed this with my wife every time we
watch something on netflix or amazon
whatever it is it's gross people having
sex
the last erotic scene and i said that i
saw on the film was was and i fell
asleep at the movie specter james bond
with monica bellucci right and it was
but i mean this it was actually like
erotic sexual they were attracted to
each other she was dressed nicely he was
in a he was in a tux and you're sitting
there going oh this is this is appealing
it's supposed to be look all art is
based on the beauty of the human form of
course early christians had no problem
with nudity just to be clear and now you
tune in and it's two big fat you know uh
angry lesbians uh pegging and you're
going what is what is happening they
don't want to show you the things that
you want to see they want to force upon
you things that you don't want to see i
don't know what that was that's the hard
rock i told you to look at my phone
[Laughter]
we really are at that point where there
is a social engineering taking place
that uh all right well that's just an
insane thing because does he really look
like a guy who knows the bible
yeah let me tell you that was a very
loaded statement does he really look
like a guy who knows the bible yes i
don't know if any part of that is
correct oh that's true
does she everything you just said was
wrong this is it
can't dig yourself out i don't know what
you're right i've read quite a hole yeah
well
maybe we and we don't know where the
holes are
could be new ones they made yeah
i didn't know where else to go with that
no none of us know where to go with this
so speaking of uh not knowing where to
go san francisco the mayor
of san francisco now many of you may
know this and this is going to we're
going to tie all this in here because
there is the fear-mongering that's been
going on of course
i think we're at the point where
enough americans are saying okay this is
enough when you have bill maher and
jimmy kimmel not jimmy kimmel didn't
know how to respond to them oh he's that
in a second when you have people out
there saying this is enough when you
start reopening the country we are being
absurd now when children are being
double masked and we're not letting them
go to schools
and more important than a hypocrisy that
we've seen from the left and this is
what i've always talked about whether
it's nancy pelosi in her particle vortex
yeah by the way tomorrow we'll have
jordan peterson on the show long form
whether it is uh governor whitmer going
out and getting pizza it's not that
they're hypocritical everyone is a
hypocrite okay it's that they are not
scared in the way they want you to be
scared nancy pelosi does not fear this
virus as the deadly pandemic she claims
that she's going into a blow dryer
governor whitmer does not fear it if
she's pushing tables together in the
mcdonald's ball pen these people are not
afraid of it it's that it's very clear
now transparently it's about control
case in point another one the san
francisco mayor was caught breaking her
own mask mandate
at what i again words matter but i can
only describe as a party watch for
yourself
is that a black person singing i can't
tell i don't know
i wouldn't i wouldn't have believed that
is this a poetry jam yes
that's uh
okay yeah that's that's called i wish i
were deaf comedy jam
oh that was just awful that was that was
not the best you know and you know that
if a white person is that black people
would be making fun of how you had no
rhythm and and rightfully so yeah of
course yeah and she was also there with
the black lives matter co-founder alicia
garza just to be clear and of course
this goes directly against the san
francisco mass mandate it's not that
it's hypocritical it's that those people
aren't actually scared yeah they don't
believe it they will tell you you don't
care
why don't you care about lives we're all
in this together they're not it's not
the hypocrisy and i hate it when i tune
in to fox well i don't really tune in
but when i see fox news when i see these
conservatives out there going these
hypocrites no no look look that's not
the argument
it's that they are clearly lying to you
when they tell you you need to be scared
do you have any idea that the the the
particles that are coming out of that
that that that person wasn't singing
with their diaphragm
that was all throat spit definitely well
and we were told let's get
we were told early on that you couldn't
sing in church too in california because
it was going to spray particles
throughout the place and people were
going to get sick did you hear her
response basically i don't know if you
had her response in there she's had
several so one was uh i'm not gonna like
take my mask off and sip and then put it
up and take it off it's like well you
weren't drinking for like a minute
straight or eating anything and then the
other one was well the spirit moved me
yeah and so i just had to and the other
one was i can't believe i actually saw
this this morning she said i what's
getting lost in this and it's tragic is
that tony tony tony got back together
after like 20 years or 30 years that's
the group that was singing tony spelled
three different ways mind you they got
back together and were missing the
tragedy that's the tragedy like she
literally said this on cnn like they're
like it's the beatles reuniting on a
rooftop nobody knows who that is she's
like really that's what i can't believe
this is making this a thing everybody
was vaccinated wait that was a re they
were reuniting that was their reuniting
tour okay all of 12 people can we how do
we how do we forcibly and federally
fracture them again
that wasn't just an open mic night i
thought it was just like a jam session
people came together
hey there's jazz in a basement you can
leave a dollar if you yeah
no someone calls them up and said hey
it's time to get the band back together
good idea yeah tony yeah tony yeah tony
oh it's the tony so cold in the d is a
better song yes it is
someone's going to google that's going
to get three million plays after that
it's from detroit people everyone from
detroit knows it okay so that she's just
rapping in a random graveyard
you know everyone let's have another
control room bring it up
we'll show it later in the show for mug
club members it's it's the worst song
ever well
second yeah yeah oh yeah well yeah we'll
talk about that thing because i want to
know what the first worst song ever is
so here's
uh bill maher who um i love in this
interview he was talking with jimmy
kimmel and uh he was asked about nor
mcdonald who hated bill maher yes and he
had to sort of act as though they had
mutual respect whereas every time you
know
norm was interview about bill maherty
you know you have these comedians uh i
always think that uh comedian's job you
know
primarily is uh
to be funny you know
and then you have some like bill maher
who think it's to be you know
intellectual uh like he's on there with
george will you know and uh and then he
thinks that's his job there you know i
think it's to be funny
that's all he would say about bill maher
but bill maher was talking with jimmy
kimmel
about and this is him trying to line his
pockets because now he's mad that of
course people aren't coming out to the
shows but i want you to see the dynamic
here and that jimmy kimmel doesn't
really know how to respond where bill
maher does bring up a recent poll that
shows just how out of touch
all not some all democrats as a
statistical population democrats
liberals are with the statistical
reality of covet hospitalization rates
and uh watch uh uh jimmy kimmel uh laugh
more uncomfortably than if he was at uh
what's that band donny tony tony tony
tony toe johnny tony yeah i have to cite
a survey that was in the new york times
which is a liberal paper so they weren't
looking for this answer
but
they were talking about uh the question
was what do you think the chances are
that you would have to go to the
hospital if you got coveted
and
democrats thought that was way higher
than republicans
41 of democrats and the answer is
between one and five percent okay
41 percent of democrats thought it was
over 50
another 28 thought it was 20 to 49 so 70
percent of democrats thought it was way
way way higher than it really was
liberal media has to take a little
responsibility for that
for scaring the [ __ ] out of people
and the reason why
it's much harder for every touring actor
talking about youtube in blue state oh
interesting they're afraid to go out of
the house
oh interesting i don't know how to deal
with this is there an audience are you
talking about me there i guess there is
but neither one of them are interested
in making them laugh yeah they don't
know what to do no there there was they
talked about pot for like the first
seven minutes of the interview and the
audience was totally into that yeah
they want to show how cool they are like
well the thing is uh
you know folks i used to smoke pot uh
people say to you know me that's the
bill martin is always an inside joke
like well you know you know me that i uh
i like well i like drugs
that's a miracle i've not been me too
yeah it's america he talked about hiding
pot behind his balls while traveling on
airplanes yeah who hasn't
i am surprised he hasn't been me too
it's a good pocket no i am too because
he's always remember this everything's a
perfect thing it's like him in 11
blondes yeah yeah yeah no he likes uh he
likes black women too does he yeah he
likes black women he tastes like
exclusively like playboy models uh also
well speaking of black people we're
going to talk about trudeau and a little
what what yeah what a great guy yeah
bill i mean he's willing to date a black
playboy model he will never have me
he will never have me on his show no
didn't make it through the screener
because i'm not as sharp as the
republicans i have on that show
but i spoke with the screener and then
they were like oh oh oh
let's not do this we'll call you yeah
we'll call you um so the poll he's
talking about from the new york times 41
of democrats believe the risk for
hospitalization was 50 or more
wow that's so insane compared to only 28
of republicans 10 percent only 10
percent of democrats got it right
unbelievable that it was a one to five
percent hospitalization rate now keep in
mind notice if every other person was in
the hospital i know it really is really
is insane well here's the thing too that
they they um they don't understand is uh
this also includes anyone who's admitted
to the hospital who tests positive for
covet incidentally so if i go in for
example for the surgery and i test
positive for covid that's a
hospitalization so even with that number
it's one to five percent yeah we need to
start putting this in context at what
point can we say all right
okay overreaction i think the tides are
turning yeah did you see how bad those
numbers were bring that if you can bring
the overlay back up then republicans and
independents it is permeated throughout
it's nice it's pretty high it's worse
than democrats way worse but you can see
those other the bottom two categories
over 20 percent and up to 50 and more
like so many people believe that you're
going to the hospital if you get covered
period you're done you're going to the
hospital it's going to be a severe case
the statistical chance of you going to
the hospital if you have covet is very
very low and the statistical chance of
you having covert if you get sick right
now is very low there's a there's a much
stronger likelihood that you have
something else right another flu cold
allergies sinus infection this is a
statistical reality and my doctor made
it very very clear said there's a you
probably have something else yeah it's a
10 10 maybe 15 chance that you have
coveted and you'd probably asymptom you
probably have something else and we're
not keeping we're not keeping this in
context right no all the other bugs
didn't just decide to take a day off
because
on the block it's like i guess we don't
have to kill people this year yeah
my last physical they had everything
my last physical was just tony tony tony
actually
so uh oh by the way the best thing you
can do on the show is comment i want to
ask you
why do you think the left in canada may
forgive this guy trudeau with black face
he's done black we're going to go
through that all the time he's done
blackface he might win the prime
minister do we have enough time i have
no idea
well because his different costumes make
up 13 of the black people
and the other then the remainder is just
one haitian immigrant stop doing that
i am that's enough i keep thinking i'm
you but i'm not you you're like which
one's which don't shoot any of us
don't confuse us
so uh chris rock being a black guy he uh
just announced that he has covid now
here's the thing of course no one's
happy about the fact that he had code he
said no he said hey guys just five i
have coven trust me you don't want this
get vaccinated
except chris rock is vaccinated yeah he
is vaccinated what does that make sense
despite being fully
vaccinated it's weird to call him mr
rock as they did in that quote they
called him mr rock yeah pull it back up
mr rock to mr right there
for the rock i know tony
which one though i only i'm only
familiar with tony
this
jaw
something that is important a lot of
people don't realize this this is the
most likely scenario at this point
because there's a significant portion of
the population or vaccinated and so a
lot of people say well the reason that
the majority of people in israeli
hospitals
are vaccinated is because a majority of
the population sure absolutely that's
true however
we were all sold a bill of goods that
once you were vaccinated you wouldn't
end up in the hospital we were initially
sold that you were protected remember
the term i don't know if you remember
this term
we used to fill out sheets right dave
yes he's come on dave he's what he's his
eyes
that's the novocaine he's taking him out
of milk um did you say novocaine
we get my teeth drilled later remember
you have to fill out forms as a kid do
you know what it it used to say
immunizations yeah yes well that's not a
thing anymore
why well because we're not immunizing
people oh we're right now this is we're
protecting now it's not an immunization
this is important for people to know
people thought they were being immunized
against covet right well yeah you
weren't now it doesn't mean that the
vaccine is not helpful doesn't mean that
it doesn't reduce hospitalizations yeah
however that's not why many of you got
vaccinated right it was the same reason
that you all said and this is an
argument that was making the rounds
again on twitter this weekend saying oh
well republicans are dumb they're just
going to kill off their base if they
don't get vaccinated if that's true then
let republicans die and decrease the
surplus population you don't believe it
you don't believe it because the
statistics show us right now that the
majority of people who are hospitalized
or majority of people who are going into
emergency rooms or receive are getting
coveted are vaccinated yeah and this
comes out uh from israel this is at
washington post i think we have the
overlay uh it was a 700 000 person study
and they found that people who had been
naturally infected were 27 times
less likely to have a second symptomatic
covet infection than vaccinated people
now how did i stumble across this
desantis said it the media said that he
was crazy yeah then politifact and
snopes said it was mostly correct now
actually if we bring that up to santa's
politifact and snopes they said desantis
was mostly correct no he's entirely
correct 27 times correct with a very
large sample study by the way the reason
this is very important the data coming
from israel just so you know is because
they do have a massive sort of
socialized health care system where
everyone avails all of their personal
information i don't want that here but
they're taking advantage of it there
while they have it huge sample size huge
portion of the population who's
vaccinated and it is
on
it's undoubted right now
that it's not working the way that
people thought it was working and
natural immunity is 27 you're 27 times
less likely i can't say 27 times more
likely to uh not get coveted again
here's the thing
they changed the name or they changed
the definition of vaccine well they
changed the definition of the protection
that the vaccine provides right it used
to be immunized now it's protection and
it's protection against hospitalization
but what we're dealing with here when
we're talking about the israeli study
and the fact check is desantis said this
and it was mostly correct however that
same that study may not necessarily be
super accurate because in israel we
don't know people the severity uh how
many vaccines they've had we don't have
all this information and by the and then
they say by the way that study did show
that the most effective is natural
immunity plus vaccine okay how do you
know that's definitive how can you say
the initial statement of 27 times less
likely to recontract covet if you have
natural immunity is not definitive but
then a sub set of data saying that
natural immunity plus a vaccine is more
effective how can you make one statement
definitive and the other
general and this is also important
can we agree at a certain point you guys
comment anyone who's vaccinated people
who are not vaccinated because i know we
have liberals out there i know we have
leftists who watch the show can we agree
if natural immunity makes us 27 times
less likely to recontract covet than the
vaccine it's more effective yeah let's
say natural immunity plus
and i haven't been able to find this
number plus the vaccine makes you 28
times less likely can i weigh the risk
and reward of myocarditis with the cdc
had to host an emergency meeting about
at a certain point can i say you know
what natural immunity is enough
when can i make a decision for my own
health well people are losing their jobs
if they don't well nobody nobody is
taking into account the natural immunity
right so people that have had coveted
before you still have to get a shot and
have a vaccine passport but let me bring
this up because you said they don't
believe it that's a strong claim right
that they don't believe um that that you
know these vaccines are working because
they're having to boost your shots and
you know you know who doesn't believe
that vaccines are going to protect you
completely from getting covered joe
biden he said it in his mandate when he
said companies that had 100 employees or
more had to get vaccinated he said i'm
going to protect the vaccinated from the
unvaccinated how do you do that joe what
are you protecting them from yeah
they're vaccinated already are you
saying that they can get covet
at a high rate and that's why we have to
protect them they don't believe in this
stuff you know a sudden fauci he cited
the israel study and said oh well it's
it's more you know it's definitely there
but we don't know how long it's going to
last you know what he didn't say it's 27
times more likely to keep you from
having another coveted case by having it
he didn't say that number i haven't
heard that from anybody else you haven't
heard that that number from him either
because he's been trying to argue with
uh the fda over uh the boosters yeah
which they're like actually we don't
really think they should be giving
boosters to uh you know teenagers he's
like ah you sure
i have shock advisor do it now it just
makes common sense do it well they're
not looking but at that point it's a pin
prick they don't know the difference
i'm a plush toy now yeah so israel 80 of
their adult population vaccinated wow 10
000 new cases supported september uh
were reported on september 13th 60 of
gravely ill-covered patients in israel
were among people fully vaccinated as of
august 31st um and they've a per they've
approved a third booster shot look this
is one thing
let me just speak to this this is not
medical advice
whatsoever i'm just going to explain
what i just went through okay and the
problem with youtube and the problem
with social media is they'll try and
hold what i'm about to say which is
entirely anecdotal
to the standard of medical advice it's
not my parents had covet they're fine
my wife had coveted tested positive the
only reason my wife went and got tested
was because i was feeling sick yeah i
tested negative i have now tested
negative five times over the span of
eight or nine days yeah eight or nine
days my wife and i have been hanging out
sharing drinks you know swapping you
know
yeah
so i asked my doctor how does this
happen he said well you either had
natural immunity uh
or uh i don't know that's pretty much it
you have natural immunity or we don't
know so here's the thing this is what i
have been doing and i've had people in
this office doing it and this is at the
advice of my doctor just the onl this
has been my protocol just so you know
been taking zinc and quercetin every day
uh knack the n-acetyl cysteine which
we've talked about which has been been
used as an expectorant for a long time
and increases glutathione in your in
your lungs and in your liver and then
doing a xylitol saline nasal rinse okay
none of these things are sponsors just
want to be clear but the whole idea
behind it was to reduce a viral load
this was done based on all of the
clinical evidence that i found before me
and i will say
either worked in the sense that i
was asymptomatic and already had it or
it worked and that i never got it yeah
but i have been surrounded by people
who've had covet
maybe i have a natural immunity because
of my blood type i don't know all i'm
saying is that i tried to take health
into my own hands i tried to stay as
healthy as i could and it worked and we
can't even talk about this right now no
one can talk about health diet exercise
supplements
for fear of being banned right and now
we're all reliant on a leaky vaccine
where people are still being put on
ventilators yeah and we can't talk about
therapeutics which that used to be the
main line of defense and you and i have
talked about why that probably is and
we'll get into that i'm not going to say
it here because it could possibly get us
banned from
the channel that we are on even though
it's it's within the fda's guidelines it
won't get banned when they come out with
the uh the new time released uh neither
fecton
[Laughter]
new patent oh so what they're gonna do
is pull it off the market and then make
it a prescription only and raise the
price yeah that's never happened well
here's something else too by the way my
family and my wife got uh antibodies uh
the regeneron treatment you know now joe
biden has to ration it
let's be clear the reason this is being
rationed and the rules are changing is
because there's not enough for the
people who are vaccinated let's just be
clear people who are going and getting
antibody treatment it's the same about
the same percentage of people who make
up the population who are vaccinated in
other words it's not only unvaccinated
people who need antibodies at this point
because vaccinated people are getting
sick
this is something that is actually
happening across the country right now
and we people point to florida they try
to say desantis got money from the the
company that created reject well florida
had the earliest rollout one of the most
effective rollouts and one of the
highest vaccination rates and they made
regeneron available they made antibody
treatment antibody treatments available
to everybody when family members went in
they were in rooms you're in rooms with
four five six people and a majority of
them were vaccinated and to be clear
when i went into a clinic just just to
give you an idea as to how far gone
we've gone as a country when i went into
the clinic my wife left positive tests
yeah i told them look i have a negative
home test so i go in for the more
accurate test they test me they say it's
negative and this nurse this snooty
snotty nurse says well it's negative but
uh you know you just treat it like a
positive 10-day quarantine don't go to
work don't see your kids i'm like oh you
must be a liberal you think i can just
end my life for 10 days because it's the
only thing they take into account it
can't always be only safety if you're 27
times less likely to get it when you've
had it naturally do we shut down the
economy for 28 times less likely yeah
okay one honest question how is that a
vaccine
yeah it just doesn't make any sense it's
really a therapeutic it does a great job
of hospitalizations and severe cases it
lowers death rates those are all
fantastic things but that's not how it
was sold to us no and now the goal posts
keep moving by the way uh pfizer the
company that we can absolutely 100 trust
they're always right yes never any drugs
coming back off the market no uh they
said that the vaccine is now this
happened this morning that it's fine for
five to eleven wow so the fda is going
to have like parker brothers but uh yes
they studied twenty-five so i saw drugs
yeah exactly so five to eleven-year-olds
and people are like oh thank god it's
about time and i'm like you mean
the age group just look it up i'm not
even going to say go to cdc's website
we're going to look at that age group up
and you tell me look up five little
that's the thing right now
it could be i don't know i'm just saying
go look it up it's a good question
that's a scary time no that's disgusting
yeah yeah whatever yeah whatever okay
maybe get a vaccine that works
i don't know just throwing that up
change this just can we change the name
to be pulled off of this or worrying
about being pulled off a platform by
simply stating facts yeah is absurd i
think we're allowed to ask hey how can
you still get coveted after the vaccine
if everybody was still getting smallpox
and stuff
yeah we'd like people you had the thing
and you still got the pucks
rickets yeah exactly why is that guy
walking like brooks from shawshank oh
the rick ricketts i thought we got rid
of that well we did we said we did but
you know
it's leaky not so much yeah we have no
idea how it really works and let me tell
you the one thing too the list of side
effects for monoclonal antibodies i have
the sheet yeah i've never seen a shorter
list of side effects oh my zyrtec my
daily allergy medicine has a higher list
of side effects and they told family
members they said hey by the way once
you get these antibodies uh don't get a
vaccine for 90 days because it'll undo
the natural antibodies that was
interesting and i'm going hold on a
second
90 days you have what about a surge
we're talking about flattening the curve
and i said is there any way is there any
way when i ask these people and doctors
i said is there any way for example to
maybe use these preventatively have we
looked at that if it lasts for 90 days
you're warning people to not take a
vaccine for 90 days because the
antibodies are still active this is what
they told us they said well we haven't
been able to study that because our
study has been right now on on treatment
first off that's [ __ ] they haven't
been studying treatment we all know that
right now they're not studying available
treatments second i'm going if you give
this to two million people you mean to
tell me that you can't study giving an
antibody treatment with effectively zero
side effects to five ten thousand to see
if it reduces their chances of
symptomatic covid you can't possibly
include that as an arrow in your quiver
of studies they have no interest in it
it's remarkable right now it's vaccine
or bust and unfortunately the vaccine is
a bust okay
talking about china
oh do we have to woof blue uh shang chi
is that the name of this i don't follow
them is that even a real marvel thing it
seems like an invention
i love it did you see it do you watch
these because i know with your son i
like it with plum sauce
uh no i didn't watch special day with my
son because why yeah look like trash oh
you watched cruella i figured you need
to wash the pallet with something
masculine well
come on no i just watched america's next
top model and
turn them on to rupaul's drag race
well
discussing him earlier her however yeah
320 million dollars this film's amassed
but what is kind of remarkable is china
won't let it play oh why uh they claim
that the character is racist oh
but really their problem is with simulus
the actor his previous comments about
china where he basically said that it
was a third world country that people
were
were starving oh um you know telling the
truth yeah yes there's a couple actors
in there that china does not like
because of things that they've said in
the past yeah if you go to a movie in
china is it all the same like you get
the same popcorn and the same it's all
equal i have no idea one size chicken
one you really can't be like i get a
larger like that's not how this works
that's not how this works you get this
bucket you get small
and it's empty yeah you get empty bucket
go sit watch movies and uh make no sound
so uh you want butter on your bucket the
second by the way most popular movie
this weekend was a candy man and since
china they have a problem with black
people too they made changes to the
chinese cut we found with ken yeah it's
a little bit different full face
replacement yeah also brac panted too so
um
let's go i'm gonna just put the mask the
interview though with this actor is no
longer available on the cbc website just
criticize china my concern is not with
communist china
my concern is with cbc removing this
interview that criticizes communist
china yeah my concern is always with big
tech and big media organizations who
work together to remove criticism of
china i mean this is sort of an
exaggerated version of what we saw with
red dawn remember they switched it to
north korea yes we can't offend the
chinese market um here's the thing if
we're interested in in our freedom as a
nation and remaining in the united
states um we should seek to offend the
communist chinese government i think at
is that canadian broadcasting company is
that what you're saying is cbc uh
yeah cbc was where the interview was
is canadian just making yeah he's
canadian oh i didn't know that mm-hmm so
you do now canadian who's not able to
have a film in china right got it and he
also got in trouble because he praised
uh one of his favorite uh beverage
companies vita soy uh which i guess is
based in hong kong of course they don't
play very nice with hong kong china i
think we have a clip right that's all
what's up gq i'm simon liu and these are
my essentials first we gotta talk about
asian snacks so many asian kids like
myself when we brought these snacks to
school we used to get made fun of right
because the kids wouldn't know what they
were so now we're here to demystify them
lemon tea drink from veda lunchbox
staple look
i don't want to vilify an entire nation
of people so i want to be clear china's
a horrible place donald trump don't
trust china china
we're talking about the communist
chinese government correct
i know
this government that allowed mulan to
film there which basically shoved
muslim uyghurs out of the way to film it
we need a concentration camp to film
that so you guys are going to have to go
on vacation for a minute and cut rocks
right with your toes
difficult
skill labor and this forced us to do a
little bit of left a a little bit of a
reading apparently this guy you were
telling me this guy from uh from uh
xinjiang
yeah
yeah
he's a little based he might be more
right-leaning there were some reddit
posts that we found and i guess he he
wrote i'm all about gender equality
however girls are just not as good as
boys at sports and whenever i play
volleyball
uh he wrote this on reddit yeah he wrote
a while ago verified account it was him
he said it makes him frustrated he said
whenever i play volleyball with the girl
on the team i always get frustrated
yeah well there's some other comments
too so maybe not all based maybe
frustrated with you being a boy on their
volleyballs that could be it too it
could be that or it could just be you
know maybe not a boy it could be a jesus
in the volleyball that's true spike um
are you zack morris from the gang
so hold on let me make sure that i have
this clear marvel panders to china by
making a movie about chinese culture
with an all chinese cast
they're speaking mandarin in the movie
if i have this correct but china cancels
the movie anyway
[Music]
why i have no interest in watching the
movie so i it doesn't matter no oh well
then yeah you're good yeah you're good
watching youtube are you serious that's
a marvel thing yeah yeah i didn't see
any cards i have the sets i didn't see
changi or whatever the hell it is he's
based on bruce lee his
father's whatever
based on bruce lee
you just kind of think that no it's
based on bruce lee but i mean it's not
his name
well we're talking about this also
aquafina has gotten in trouble uh
because apparently she has her black
scent well good or using her
the name aquafina yeah i don't i put a w
in it i put a w in it and ripped off a
song called my penis but just turned it
to my vagina and i got a career because
they needed a moderately entertaining
asian girl on youtube and now i have a
career that uh is completely unwarranted
i picked the worst water too yeah it's
worse than dishonored i'm gonna pick the
water that tastes like wet pennies
well i mean
look at the money you're not going to
pick the most upscale water no you're
not going to she's not going to be
selling uh
she's no ozarka a guy asked for
sparkling water next to me on my plane
today and i was just like yeah go to
hell man
yeah come on like you're like sparkling
water you don't like the bubbles dave no
it's obnoxious though to be like i'll
take sparkling
water thank you
i'm better than all of you you were on
spirit airlines though dave no wow
should have known what happened to all
those what happened to stop the asian
hate crimes remember that it used to be
a thing it used to be a thing i guess
now we forgot hey is it considered an
asian hate crime when you actually uh
have people who are being imprisoned
with uh yeah
you know in china when you have people
there who are public conscientious
objectors or people who are actually
being banned from the country i just i
just i'm a little bit confused not to
mention of course the anti-asian hate
crimes are by large committed uh by
people of african american uh african
americans about asians here in the
united states this is just we don't talk
about that
so basically this is a movie
for rich white people this is a movie
for white feminists and masks to feel
like they understand asian culture and
china bans it just like you feel as
though you're eating chinese food with
your general so chicken but really you
know their street food is is scorpion
fried and rat [ __ ] hmm don't forget
about the bats that is true don't forget
the baby friend said they eat a lot of
chicken feet uh by the way the best
thing you can do tune into the show
monday through thursday it's a live show
10 a.m eastern that's the best thing you
can do uh you can follow us of course on
apple itunes where are you hitting there
hit the trigger
boom there we go
and uh we have a big ass interview with
jordan peterson tomorrow interview
so justin trudeau uh there's a new photo
now mm-hmm
prime minister for people who don't know
from canada there's still a thing yes oh
well he really has a recall election
they asked me to be on megan uh kelly
this week i don't know if i'll be doing
it but they wanted me to be on as their
uh
their like sort of canadian
correspondent i said i don't have any
interest in
i don't follow it anymore it's such a
silly place it's irrelevant
i would like it i'd follow it if it were
a state
blackface we should just make it a state
got a lot of resources we can be like
all right canada you're you know state
the fact that canada is allowed to exist
is proof that we are the only nation
that has not been the e can you imagine
the ottomans yeah like canada to the
north it's like wait a second they have
no defense whatsoever
none bounties how many resources all the
natural resources all of them population
is a tenth of our population what what
they're they just walk up there and take
it their air force is a guy in an old
cessna propeller plane with a shotgun
and we're letting them have it how do
they pronounce a bout
yeah exactly well that's enough that's
just that's the clincher so there's
another picture that's come out um
justin trudeau and blackface from the
2001 arabian nights party
gosh he was just discovered this past
weekend before no hold on please let's
try to get photo because i love here's
the thing here's what people are missing
with this he is deliberately showing his
tongue to contrast that he's in black
face it's true he wants you to know in
other words if he if that picture if you
were just sort of walking and you were
butting up you wouldn't be like oh i
don't know maybe that's a darker guy but
he's going like look i'm racist
when he doesn't go just like a little
brown he goes like
dark
are you sure he's not just dressed as
kazam
[Laughter]
maybe it's his favorite movie yeah
by the way last time he was asked about
this he couldn't recall how many times
he had done blackface
just to be clear
he's like
so many times
this guy has a i didn't know there he
there must be a name he must have a
fetish for blackface yeah yes i mean
this guy has done it i think we have a
bunch of this is this the one where he's
asked is this the clip the the one that
has me in tears laughing is that the
next one or is it the one after that
it's gotta be this one yeah is it this
one okay so this is one that actually
remember this clip in 2019 where he was
asked about blackface yeah and then they
asked if there were any other instances
of him doing blackface
and uh
i about i i think i was on air and i
almost lost
i think i almost died
laughing so hard here we go
i want to begin oh no this is the this
is the other one saying a few words
directly to uh racialized canadians who
face racialized discrimination
every single day
in their lives even in a country like
canada
um what i did
uh hurt them
uh hurt people not even in a country
like canada you're the only one
tolerance and discrimination because of
that to you
this is something uh that
i deeply deeply regret black face
darkening your face
regardless of the context or the
circumstances
is always unacceptable that's not true
because of the racist history of
blackface i'll tell you what
oh this is
2001
when i was a teacher out in vancouver
i attended an end-of-year gala where the
theme was arabian nights
and i
dressed up in an aladdin costume
and put makeup on
black face that's the only time in your
life you've ever done something like
that when i was in high school i
dressed up at a talent show
and sang dale
[Laughter]
is that the only time you've ever done
it uh uh you know uh potentially the
most racist song that's ever existed
yeah i did that while doing a very
racist thing as well okay thanks can i
move on to my credit it was a serious
question we watched you wash off
blackface before the interview
no other times you've worn it
that's the follow-up question sir are
there any more times
yeah so uh in middle school
and he's like well yeah don't we have a
collage here of all the other times i
mean look at this
he's prolific look and he's always he
knows the camera is there and he's
smiling like ah
everyone get me on camera he's like you
know he's he's like uh he's like a you
know a
fruitcake in sequence who just wants to
be seen
why the hat
i mean it's arabian knights you gotta
have the hat what about the other one to
an arabian nights party though i mean
it's yeah he went out of his way he went
out of his way he could have done
something different and by the way if
you could wear an aladdin costume you
could and not paint yourself black it's
almost as though people would be
confused like if you just put on the
aladdin costume like oh you're aladdin
but once you have black face like what
are you supposed to be no i'm black
aladdin well that's a weird stretch go
blue aladdin yeah he could have been
just fine he just didn't want blue and
by the way i said i said you could do
blackface any time if you're a navy seal
about to go and take down a village at
night black troops totally acceptable
bodybuilding you can do that there
especially if it's baltimore
or if you're making a movie robert
downey jr um do we have another graduate
we have another yeah we do have another
so he has had to apologize for this
repeatedly look it's hilarious the point
is he's probably going to win
re-election in canada the argument when
people try and go after keep in mind
megan kelly was cancelled because she
said you know when we were young you
know you had girls dress up like diana
ross they weren't thinking that they
loved the supremes you know they weren't
trying to be racist she goes i don't
think that that's the same as a minstrel
show in blackface was fired for that
statement and this man who is the
darling of the media
the leftist media this has been his own
he is a blackface connoisseur it's what
he does
the outrage is fake no one actually
cares and i i honestly i am surprised
this guy has just not gotten
the [ __ ] kicked out of him by a black
guy well there's not many up there there
aren't many but the other one haitian
guy like stop
i'll get you i'm at the end of my rope
so let's uh here here's some mountains
i'm having to apologize non-stop this
has been going on for years have a look
it's pretty grainy uh we wanted to be
very sure that this was in fact
like bigfoot
smiling at the camera to us last night
that we are looking at justin trudeau in
this video you can see that he has black
face makeup on it's covering his face
neck his arms and hands and you can see
between the tears and his jeans there
that he also on his legs
jim morrison was hanging out in the
fireworks
image of him within about 12 hours that
has come out
and initially broken by time magazine
oh god guys
what an ass
i just i'm not as bothered by him as i
am by the fact that the media tries to
it's just the selective outrage is
unbelievable and i don't think that you
should be going around i'm not offended
by it but it's getting close
he went he went all the way away
his arms his entire body he's a
fetishist this is the truth no one wants
to acknowledge it he's like hoover
walking around dressed up like a dame
this guy likes he likes looking at
himself in the mirror and doing a
there's a weird sexual thing he's much
cooler as a black man i'll be honest i'd
walk up the line that guy all right dave
wake up what you're literally falling
asleep i see his eyes i told you i i'm
not right asleep yeah
so uh where's my black this is something
else to happen this weekend have you
guys been following them now they've
tried to be quiet about it at cnn
but they covered it this morning quite a
bit the j6 remember the rally yeah the
honey that was supposed to happen this
weekend that we talked about last week
saying this is not a real thing we don't
know anyone who's
um ted liu claimed that anyone who was
going to show up to this well so i want
to cover i want to explain to you
exactly how the media covered it
what they said you should believe versus
what actually happened and let me just
spoiler alert there was there was one
arrest
undercover agent it wasn't really an
arrest so i just wanted to lead with
that so you know
before you think like oh maybe this is
worse than i thought no no no it's it's
absolute nothing but the media still
wants you to believe it's something that
you need to be concerned about ted lou
claimed that anyone who showed up was a
traitor uh here's uh ted lou looking
like uh uh he's in the the interview the
rally near the capitol supporting the
hundreds of people that have been
arrested and charged in the january 6
insurrection
what do you think is behind these people
calling for justice
if republicans want to prevent the risk
of further political violence all they
have to do is say one
simple truthful sentence
the election was not stolen
the refusal to do that and to keep
promoting the big lie is harmful to our
democracy and it's going to result in
further political how about middle parts
the people who showed up on january 6
and assaulted our capital johnny five
heroes they're traders insurrectionists
and anyone showing up today to support
those people also are of the same
mindset and it's highly disturbing that
you still have people in america who
want to take our democracy and destroy
it so
they tried to make january 6th out to be
obviously like almost as big as let's
say the summer of love riots and
billions of dollars in damages and
thousands of officers casualties to
officers so they tried to make this out
to be january 6 part 2. we talked about
it last week yeah no one who we knew was
going we said it wouldn't be you
absolutely shouldn't be going down um so
what did they do they installed new
fence and motion tracking right a watch
tower wow outside the capitol uh they
had all the security a wall
yeah a wall you can believe it um they
had riot police show up in full-on
battalion gear uh and then uh what
happened was no one showed up and so
they built this up and now they had to
pivot and ted lou said that well no one
showed up so the media said no one
showed up because this is this is now
indicative of trump's waning in france
right you can bring that up there that's
what ted lou tweeted and this was echoed
by newsweek they tried to say the very
small crowd size of the justice for six
traitorous rally shows the waning
influence of former president trump
trump actually warned just to be clear
he warned people not to go
he said this is ridiculous this is his
actual quote on saturday that just set
up
if people don't show up they'll say oh
it's a lack of spirit and if people show
up they'll be harassed don't go and then
ted lewis says so this is what they try
to do if it was big enough they would
say donald trump is fermenting hatred
right if it's small enough they go see
trump doesn't have influence well how
about the truth maybe trump did have
influence telling people not to go yeah
he was spot on with all three of those
statements they have been the left has
been claiming that this is the party of
donald trump and that he is the guy
behind the scenes pulling the strings he
you can't have it both ways ted he's one
or the other he is this evil genius that
is taking over the country or he's a guy
that can't get more than 300 people to a
rally which by the way his history with
rallies it's pretty good it's pretty
good people that's that's kind of that's
kind of his thing he's the biggest
you know it's like well look thrice
married and i was impeached no longer
president but
listen to that chair look at him they
could never take that away from me and
it's true that's his thing his people
love him so it's not an argument that
they would want to make no now how did
the media try and frame this event they
said four arrests were made right again
this is available you can see it at nbc
newsweek uh what happened well okay
there was from what i've seen and it's
really hard to get any information
because of course they don't want you
getting information one person was
detained
and this person i think we have the
video
the one person with the firearm who
showed up for who was armed undercover
cops
i'm just here are you undercover don't
blow it man not blowing my cover don't
blow it in front of my four colleagues
who made you undercover i did it was me
then they pull out his badge and he
leaves without being arrested that's so
funny but you can find the screen grabs
right and you can what's so funny is
when you watch this footage you just see
reporters going through right with their
stabilizing cameras and they're trying
to get all these shut there was no one
there these were the guys who showed up
just to be clear look these glow sticks
were the other attendees who showed up
yeah
oh look at that fbi they got here let's
dress like douche bags and go to this
thing they won't see us coming
i don't know if that's douchebags those
are christmas glow worms they are
oh that is do we have any video of the
other three that they say were arrested
no this oh no or records at least at the
time of this
segment it's only one confirmed almost
arrest so let me go through this again
for people who missed it we'll have a
link in the description all of the
references are available at
lateralwithcrowder.com but last week we
talked about the fbi and we talked about
how they have been doing this for a very
long time there's a huge difference
between infiltrating an organization and
happening to find or intercept some
violent criminal activity taking place
and actually trying to stage an event or
inspire a violent event so that you can
capture people one is doing your job the
other is effectively entrapment so
um what do we have there the fbi of
course they interviewed uh the parkland
shooter well before the shooting
happened yeah pulse nightclub shooter
the boston bomber they didn't report
michaela maroney's abuse this happened
last week by larry nasar for 17 months
over 40 more women were raped sexually
assaulted sexually harassed uh of course
the militia whitmer plot we went through
all this last week about half of the
people involved with the plot and almost
all of the people who actually
encouraged violence were members of the
fbi or senior intelligence agencies um
and of course there was the uh the
it's just the fbi has done this nonstop
liberty 7 or liberty liberties we did
the whole thing last week this is what
they attempted to do this time but just
on a smaller scale and they had the
media ready no one showed up and you
could argue no one showed up why because
donald trump don't show up yeah yeah
well then people like us too were like
what what is what are you talking about
like a rally i heard about it last time
i knew there was going to be a rally
last time millions of people went to it
this time were like what are you doing
this is like totally acceptable don't
say nobody showed up fbi agent show
that's true fbi agents showed up yeah in
force a couple of us marshals yeah we
almost arrested each other
yeah
so many packed in there just some guy
being interviewed by stephanopoulos he
has a maga hat on like oh he looks
credible what are you there with the
january 6th the number two i'm here to
search every outhouse townhouse
penthouse penthouse
i want a three mile accord upriver down
river huh you're just uh you're a trump
supporter uh correct
um i think it's like that spiderman meme
they're like pointing at each other
they're all just you fbi did anyone out
there anyone out there actually go has
anyone uh has anyone out there actually
gone to this was anyone attending to any
insurrection yeah exactly a fake
insurrection yeah who hasn't oh look
pfizer right now on cnn low dose vaccine
safe for children ages five to ten kids
in this trial
oh five to eleven i'm sorry two ones
they extended the cut off one that's
true if poppy harlows hey you know what
else is safe for uh kids ages five to
eleven
coped
relatively relatively speaking
relatively speaking is i'm just saying
as long as they're not you're talking
about the vaccine i'm just saying
oh god
that is not medical advice that is of
course not medical no i just i i i don't
know we're at this point when do we when
do we get over talking about i'm so
exhausted with it at this point my wife
just went she said this is the reason
there was a toilet paper shortage
i've not met one person who's had it
that hasn't been like this is why we
shut down the country for two years yeah
this i haven't met a single person it's
anecdotal but statistically
it's also the reality
and then you have people like michael
buble michael buble canceled the show my
parents were going to go see him in
texas he said oh he sucks in austin he
said they are not uh they are not
following my protocols strongly enough
and i will not perform unless there's
not a single person in danger
you mean a person with an ear shot
it's the excuse for the rest of your
career so uh i'm moving on amy schumer
uh she had her uh she just had her
uterus removed
right now to um what's going on uh what
is happening what
what the heck was that
so she had her uh uterus continue
removed as part of a procedure
uh that um just
what the heck
hey guys whistleblower here recently
stephen crowder took a long hiatus from
his show because of some bad
complications from surgery apparently
his lung collapsed or something but
don't feel too bad for him yet because
i'm here to tell you that everything
went according to plan
buckle up because this one gets crazy
steven crowder is actually
amy schumer
[Music]
i got into this rabbit hole after
noticing amy schumer was taping her new
tv series around the same time crowder
was going into surgery
this proves that chowder is surgically
augmenting himself every time he goes on
vacation to live his second life as amy
schumer
think about it they use their rivalries
with each other to make themselves more
famous playing both sides so they always
win
and i already know what you're thinking
what about the time they were both on
fox news i'm already two steps ahead of
you it's a classic hollywood split frame
trick
so now the only question that remains is
which came first the chowder
or the schumer
or are they something different all
together
that's all for now i'll see you guys in
the next one whistleblower out
i'm sorry about that we need to tighten
up security
yeah i apologize for that you need to
tighten up the security on the slow news
station jeez
um i wanted to talk about this is just
sort of since there's nothing really
super topical right now this is
something that's going on for that
we don't want
yeah i don't want other people i don't
want any copycats all right i'm just
uh
i didn't know we had sex
[Laughter]
i think we need to talk about the
the military right now going on here in
the united states this is a fundamental
change someone asked me a question the
other day on the show saying would you
encourage your kid to go into the
military um my answer now would be no
not this one and that doesn't mean that
i don't honor and respect of course
everyone who's fought and died for a
country but i do think that the goal of
our military has changed so dramatically
recently
and i mean very quickly in the last
two years time the goal of military
should be to destroy things break stuff
win wars and stop
when wars come back home take the spoils
that's the only really that's the only
reason you should have a military now i
don't think that a lot of americans have
the stomach for that anymore no
americans don't have a stomach for what
winning a war would actually look like
see afghanistan
and i don't know people out there who
served again the best thing you could
just comment below if you served what
your view is when you were in the
military versus now and i we have a lot
of people who don't send me by the way
like your navy your navy crosses stuff
like i appreciate it but any of your
medals please i'll get them mailed to me
i really appreciate it but i think you
should keep it and pass it down to your
kids i appreciate how much the show
means to but i just
i don't have enough room on the shelf
space and i feel like everything has to
go i can't go in a drawer so please i
appreciate it don't send them give it to
your kid
a lot of people have been resigning from
the military recently or they've been
discharged from the military for
ridiculous reasons which i think you
need to look at both why are members of
the military people who are a year or
two away from their pension and this has
been happening
in huge numbers leaving why are they
leaving people who signed up for the
military and then why are people being
discharged from the military
why are people being given the boot yeah
and which p which p people are not being
given the boot
because that's what's most concerning
when you look at
what is supposed to be in a political
petri dish the military by its very
design and i'm using this term broadly
of course including all branches now
it's meant to be a woke
diversity experiment and i don't mean
diversity in that uh being
representative of the american cultural
fabric i mean you know jesus non-binary
year goes
your guess that that seal is uh your
guess is as good as mine uh type
diversity quota um so this actually was
uh uh something that started this off
and inspired it was a lieutenant colonel
stuart sheller posted this video
criticizing if you guys don't remember
this was sort of the first one the
catalyst criticizing the afghanistan
response i've got battalion commander
friends right now that are posting
similar things and they're saying
you know
wondering if all the lives were lost and
if it was in vain all those all those
people that we've lost over the last
20 years
and he goes on to say that we're all
part of a chain
while every link may not be tested the
strength of chain is only as strong as
each lincoln and you got to be you know
good link something like that
and what i'll say is
in from my position
potentially all those people did die in
vain if we don't have senior leaders
that own up and
raise their hand and say
we did not do this well in the end
without that we just keep repeating the
same mistakes this amalgamation of the
economic slash
corporate slash
political slash higher military ranks
are not
holding up their end of the bargain
i want to say this
this is articulate
i have been fighting
at the end
i am willing to throw it all away to say
to my senior leaders i demand
accountability now
after posting this he was relieved of
duty
of course so that was that was worth
being relieved of duty saying look there
needs to be some accountability for the
high ups
can you not request that when you have
13 americans dead
at what point are you allowed to say hey
is someone responsible yeah especially
when these people are in charge of
sending you yeah one truth
so um
relieved of duty and i want to contrast
that with people who have not been
relieved of duty last week uh lieutenant
colonel paul douglas uh paul douglas
hague i guess he tended his resignation
over what he this is a letter that's
been making the rounds he called a
marxist take over the military and the
vaccine mandate this is part of his
letter i want to read it to you it says
i am incapable of subjecting myself to
the unlawful unethical immoral and
tyrannical order to sit still and allow
a serum to be injected in my flesh
against my will and better judgment the
values that our nation was founded on
has lived by and thrived under have been
utterly decimated by the current
presidential administration and the
leadership of the military this guy left
i think he was a year away from pension
really two years
if i'm not mistaken
that takes balls yeah
it really does take balls to work this
hard and something you believe in and
then accept
that it is no longer what you signed up
for and uh and throw away all of the
compounding interest yeah well and those
are the two kind of people specifically
that we want to stay exactly
those are the characteristics of leaders
that we want leading men and women into
battle like that those are the people
that we want why if you're going to say
as a leader and as a leader in the
military you have to understand this
you're a part of that chain if you say
that not all all the pieces of the chain
are tested you were being tested you
failed leader yeah you have to be the
first person to put your hand in the air
take responsibility so that the people
behind you will still follow you right
how can they otherwise that was his
point we will not be able to follow you
well and be an effective military if you
don't take responsibility and someone
like that who we would argue is
these are the kind of people who would
want to stay in the military discharged
they're no longer allowed to take part
in it uh but
here are some people who are superstars
in today's military remember army staff
sergeant bronson this broad
and we're beginning to wonder where our
[ __ ] military i mean i'm no expert
but that sounded like a terroristic
threat because not you talking about a
bunch of gun owners going out and
starting a bloodbath like have you never
heard of the insurrection act there's
reasons why the military doesn't deploy
within the us and if they did your
little good old boy system is not going
to fare well for you understanding
military actually get deployed within
the united states that weapon is not
just pointed at other people other
countries it's pointed at you if you do
not get in your house when i tell you to
you become the enemy martial law you
know where your rights get curtailed you
don't have all those same freedoms that
the constitution guarantees at that
point and to be clear people were trying
to say oh actually you take that into
context you were responding to somebody
no no contextually and we'll have all
the references available kind of it's
really bad yeah yeah in other words you
had someone saying hey i can no longer
in clear conscience serve in the
military that would force me to be
vaccinated
yeah and you have a woman here who's
going i want to be in the military so i
can help force other people to be
backstated look first off she's talking
about the gun being aimed at you without
a gun you'd be thrown over my shoulder
and in a waste paper basket let's be
really clear talking tough
this is one thing and she does it quite
a bit this person as far as i know has
not been relieved of duty this person
has actually become somewhat of a star
online unless it's changed since we last
did the research uh yesterday um she has
all kinds of crazy tick tock clips look
she does them under the name i don't
know where this comes from lord daddy
nugget here's some of her
wow
lord yeah lord daddy nugget the pugsley
adams haircut and she's talking tough
like a lot of angry uh
i mean
angry just angry yeah angry
angry balls
mentally balls of little anger balls of
higher body fat percentage
pools of anger here is a montage of this
brave and beautiful thank you for
serving in our military uh lord daddy
nugget on tick tock so first and
foremost women's role in white supremacy
began long before america women had no
political power couldn't vote but one
thing they could do is own slaves the
term stud was created by black people
for black people because they still
can't do push-ups lgb community it was
then and still is now a term associated
with masculine of center black lesbian
women i'm really starting to believe
that white men who wear glasses think
that they're smart and on to some i got
really hope for your sake that you're
self-employed because i guess then the
worst that could happen is you're going
to get some really bad yelp reviews
we'll take a big red guy 40 and wipe it
with this
red guy 40s maha steps aren't seibert i
know you lying i know you're not a whole
soldier in the united states army flying
this flag i know you not a whole staff
sergeant in the united states army
talking about military suicide and you
as a non-commissioned officer should
know your place furthermore you serve
the people of the united states live the
army values and that's how you address
people come talk to this staff sergeant
that way since you want to hide behind
your ring i'll bet you won't and wear a
[ __ ] helmet how about he comes and
meets you and folds you up like a pup
tent also ironic that she's saying wear
a helmet because here is a picture of
this broad uh riding a harley so she's
not uh she's not she's not fiscally
responsible uh with a biden flag and no
helmet and by the way that's not allowed
on base off base if you're active
military that is a reason for being
reprimanded in today's military nothing
why do you think that this broad has not
been reprimanded sorry this wonderful
beautiful brave z i don't know i don't
know what this do we know what this
person is this person is out there who
is campaigning and
consistently publicly attacking other
service members nothing a guy who simply
made a statement
in general i think we need some
accountability from the higher ups yeah
gone that tells you what the goal is
does that tell you that the military
their goal right now is to have the most
effective soldiers who go out and kill
people and break stuff
because if not we shouldn't have a
military it's somebody who spends way
too much time making cuts on tick tock
did you notice that they said the word
man what is going on well they also by
the way the army banned tick-tock from
government phones in 2019 because of its
rampant security issues she's probably
taking her tick-tock from her helmetless
harley
i just hate it that's the kind of person
that makes me want to slap somebody and
i i mean i know she's
she would be fine with it because she
wants equals yeah she was challenged she
was like why don't you come over here
and talk to me
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to but she's
the kind of person that makes me do it
here's the truth women don't want
accountability that men have with other
men i was talking with my wife about
this the other day a lot of what women
would consider abuse is the way men
interact with each other yeah in the
sense that you know we rough house with
each other i was just talking with my
wife about this i remember i had a
friend a relative who was kind of drunk
and unruly yeah and i said you gotta go
and i grabbed him and took him out from
that i was like you got to go me and a
buddy grabbed him and took him out and
got him into a car yeah i realized
that's how men interact with men right
if we were to do that to a woman that's
abuse well and we know there's women
don't want us to treat them the way that
we treat men i'm not saying that you
should but i'm saying we consistently
behave with each other in a way that
would be considered abuse if it were
toward women because men are the
stronger biological sex absolutely i
don't think that we should be physical
with women of course but the point is
when a woman wants it both ways and says
why don't you come over here and
do you really want to hear that knock on
your door yeah
i don't think so you're i don't think so
i was my wife and i actually talked
about this with the uh the youtube girl
that they think they found her body
in the park and there was a police
report saying that they had both been
physically violent against each other
and i was like honey if we have a girl
like that's one of the things we have to
tell her like never act like you have
this safe place to hit a man from and
that there won't be a response now
obviously the man doesn't need to
respond
like you said stronger sex like you have
to have some restraint but at the same
time
you can't just hit a guy and think he's
not going to react right like and that's
what this girl is doing she's operating
from this safe place now she could
probably take most you know frumpy you
know antifa guys that are walking around
but not somebody who's no trained in any
kind of like martial art at all picture
the wimpiest karate picture the wimpiest
unable to do female push-ups only
planking as part of his pt requirement
aunt the guy would mop the floor with
her it would be absolutely embarrassing
it makes you understand the difference
but
you know other than that i can do
push-ups three at a time
yeah that's two
all right
it's really and from what i understand
this person hasn't been relieved of
anything now here are some more examples
uh lieutenant colonel matthew lommer he
was fired from appearing on the
conservative show steve gruber oh right
discussed his book on how marxism was
invading the united states military uh
yeah there have been quite a few
examples of people who've been banned
people who've been punished simply for
speaking out and look do we have to act
as though
at least throughout history people in
the military aren't more inherently
conservative
are inherently more freedom-loving
republican right who joined the military
and this is something else when we're
talking about the military
i don't know when it had to become
inclusive
i really don't know when it had i think
that this went wrong with women getting
the right to vote what do i mean let me
explain
whoa whoa whoa men didn't have the right
to vote unless they were a part of
mandatory draft yeah draft they had to
pay taxes mandatory bucket duty meant
you had to show up if there was a fire
if you didn't do these things you
weren't allowed to vote voting was a
privilege for men and then women so we
want the right to vote and they said
okay so part of the draft and they said
no
that rosie the reason obviously people
don't understand the history but there
are expectations with men voting and my
point here is look i i don't know when
we we got to this point where we have to
include everybody in the military yeah i
don't know why women aren't technically
included in the draft still at this
point i i want everybody who can do the
job right so this is not like a gi join
where there's a box and she can do
something differently like literally if
you can do the exact same job fine but
that has to be the standard because
we're about winning wars because
eventually another beach is probably
going to have to be stormed and it's not
going to be the trans gender person
necessarily that we're looking i don't
care if they can fight and if they can
do the job that's fine but that can't be
what you build this on and that's what
they seem to be doing right now going oh
this is more important than being strong
it's it's having this marxist ideology
we need to worry about that we need to
worry about leftists getting mad at us
because we don't have somebody else
here's the thing labeling jesus
non-binary yes exactly there's nothing
you're contributing that's my problem
it's meaningless it's absolutely fine
and here's the issue too the reason the
united states military existed at least
the reason is was to protect
the values that make the united states
of america america right the american
military went forward when you look at a
lot of to fart to fart to fight
marxist
in your face
i thought you knew that's how they got
caught by charlie hey
they're in the trees man
too no seriously we went forward to
fight marxist ideology we went forward
to fight socialist ideology we went for
because we believed in the great
experiment that was the united states of
america which was based on this idea of
federalism the idea of federal
government the idea of autonomy before
federal government a state government a
municipal government and before that the
central building block that was the
family that had their own rights to make
their own decisions and build their
communities and now we are trying to
break that away we are trying to pull at
that thread and create
a petri dish in the military instead
to foster and create an environment
where marxist ideals can thrive i'll
tell you what there if you look at this
lady this sergeant the enemy is within
who do i want in the military i'll tell
you exactly who i want in the military
not everybody who will show up and wants
to meet a diversity quota and get their
college paid for
no not in the army national
guard japan not all of those people what
i do want in the military is a guy who
believes in the united states of america
who loves his country who's proud of his
forefathers who also served and who
would be out there on the weekend with a
gun leatherneck fighting
god knows who in a bar and going out and
killing deer anyway only replaced his
deer rifle with an ar-15 and the right
to kill terrorists and marxist scum
that's the person i want in the military
and by the way he should be able to do a
few pull-ups how about that just have a
minimum requirement we wanted people in
the military we looked up to people in
the military for the same reason we
looked up the people in college at one
point in this country do you realize
that college university at one point
like if your grandmother grandfather
went big deal it was difficult because
they actually had to learn [ __ ] that
mattered
they would learn stuff that you could
they weren't doing classes on gender
studies
underwater basket weaving or on the the
the the corrosive nature of the
patriarchy through social media and tech
no they weren't doing that they were
learning things they were learning how
to do the math for the space launch they
were learning how to become nurses they
were learning how to actually teach
children you know what they were doing
in the military they were actually
learning how to destroy [ __ ] because
that's the only reason a military exists
is to destroy [ __ ] it's not the nation
built
it's not to try and build another demo
it's not to go forward and make
ourselves friends with everyone in the
world and it's certainly not to make
sure that every single demographic and
gender and whatever else is there i
don't know the gender sex whatever you
want to use depending on what we're
including the driver's license that day
get a seat at the table it is to have
the most effective force at breaking
[ __ ] and taking the stuff
that's it we should not go to war unless
we break stuff and take what's left and
we shouldn't put anyone in harm's way or
in the military who cannot break stuff
and take what's left so this is just to
give you an idea as to how far we've got
i would not want my kids to go in the
military for the same reason i wouldn't
want my kids to go to uh to an ivy
league school anymore because i'm afraid
they're going to be indoctrinated the
same way i don't want them sitting under
that drill sergeant
we'll skip that next montage really
quickly let's show the uh what what our
recruitment looked like here in this
country during world war ii
and the 90s this is how
we viewed and this is how we wanted the
world to view the united states military
no
this is not the interior of a bird cage
and the man you see obviously is not
everybody thought it was
but he does lay eggs he's training to
become a bombardier the boy who drops
these beauties where they do the most
good
we do more before 9 a.m than most people
do all day that's 80s
oh
it's a party look at my mustache
that's a porn star mustache watch me too
but just look at what they actually
tried to present there look at what they
were they you knew what the military was
so now we can react to the most recent
recruitment act
uh from the military um just let's just
roll it up all of us can watch this
again so you see how far we fall
it begins in california
raised by two moms
on the santa monica pier
[Music]
although i had a fairly typical
childhood no you didn't
play violin
i also marched for equality wow i like
to think i've been defending freedom
from an early age you're wrong my mom
ruined my saturdays
one of my moms had an accident that left
her paralyzed
doctors said she might never walk again
but she tapped into my family's pride to
get back on her feet
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other mom
that's a weird phrase role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
and then attended uc davis where i
joined a sorority full of other strong
women
were you graduation approach i began
feeling like i'd been handed so much in
life a sorority girl stereotype
sure i'd spent my life around inspiring
women
but what had i really achieved on my own
[Music]
another was climbing mount everest
i needed my own adventures
my own challenge
all throughout this there creeping some
guy hunting fishing
and dreaming of killing jihadis because
his dad went to war that's the guy yeah
and maybe shatter some stereotypes along
the way
this is them not listening to me i'm us
army corporal emma malone
and i answered my calling
well you answered something
what if we do this and this and they're
like shut up sharon
[Laughter]
we get it your moms are lesbians you
couldn't pass the plank tests
why is that the relevant fact in this
like if she can go and fight her she has
this strategic mind that is incredibly
valuable like those are the things that
i care about in the military why is the
rest of this how long was that ad that
was one minute 40 seconds it was one
minute 40 seconds and less than eight
seconds i counted were spent on her
actually doing military things yeah but
she was the mom was in an accident then
at the end of the commercial she's
climbing mount everest
shouldn't just be like and my mom died
on mount everest
and and she couldn't climb down my my
mom actually she did find me my
neighbors but then she slipped down
rolled down went back up and she died on
k-12 oh oh okay your mom should have
learned her lesson in the first accident
this time she didn't really get back on
the treadmill sort of rolled around on
it didn't know what happened to that
wedding picture
she was ready to be great none of that
is relevant no none of that is relevant
to the ability to kill people
or the ability to make sure that you
develop a and i obviously understand
that not everyone in the military is a
grunt you have commanding officers
people who do great work but developing
strategies that ultimately result in the
killing of people ultimately result in
the elimination of threats none of that
is included there i i it's one of the
it's like these new commercials where
you sit there and you watch a commercial
and there's like a parody of some song
like oh oh it's chantix you know and
you're sitting there like what the hell
was that commercial for i have no idea
that's bad is that oh
yeah
yeah i guess i don't know what it does
but the point is you should go i have no
idea what this commercial was about
that's the united states military
recruitment act yeah or are you watching
when there's like a white dad a black
mom and an asian kid and you're like so
do you two make asian
which one of you cheats
it's not that diverse anywhere
yeah well that's the other argument too
that we get brought into uh with this
and and people are gonna say this to you
like oh it's just you're the kind of
person who would only want white men in
the military no that is not the same
thing at all who's going to protect them
exactly you got to send in minorities
first then the white man
no i i realized i was agreeing with
david he turns out he was being racist
so i'm pulling that back gonna pull it
right back no what do you mean racist
you put in the lessers that's not how
this works human people who can fight
i'm just gonna keep going and so dave is
not speaking
black people and white
but that wasn't the differentiator it
was all about oh these people can fight
everybody can go i don't care what color
you are honestly i don't care who you
choose to have sex with though if you
think that's the most interesting thing
about you and you have to tell everybody
that's a bit of a problem i want people
who can fight period yeah you think if i
had two moms or two dads i really don't
care i don't think those are great
decisions but hey we're talking about
winning wars now yeah i don't mind if
you go and fight the afghans uh who you
have sex with considering you know they
like kids and sheep
and not in that order no usually it's
like no yeah i love and this is where we
are off on the sheep this is how out of
touch this is how out of touch
the american
the american military is right now it
shouldn't have worked for our leadership
our leadership is upset that they're not
that the taliban doesn't have a diverse
enough and inclusive enough government
yeah they just banned girls from high
school well what do you think they were
doing while you were creating
well you had pixar on the payroll to do
your lesbian army recruitment yeah i
haven't been able to sleep properly
since we watched a video where a guy
goes i believe it's a taliban
yeah did you just make sure that the
taliban wasn't offended
by the pronunciation of their name
that's when i gave up what are you a
woman in kabul i know what are you i
went to
you but i wasn't a strong enough woman
yeah
yeah well hey what if we go in and we
what if we go and uh can we scissor him
just shut up shannon we don't know
anything
you know who did a good job of making
like a tough woman that was james
cameron in terminator 2.
sarah connor was better she used guns
linda hamilton that wasn't somebody
trying to be woke and so i don't hold my
hand while we run like that's what it
evolved into and that was a better job
gave her a karen haircut for the new one
and ruin the day they ruined the
absolutely it was the haircut the whole
movie you're like why did you she made
her hate being a mother which is
ridiculous yeah her whole character well
look come on and then scars to get over
well it was a difficult life let's be
honest kind of come in with a little bit
of baggage i'm going to ruin the movie
real quick too
the terminator comes back and shoots
john connor like immediately and it's
like in the new one and the new one yes
the newest like it's the first thing and
you're like so
what
the whole t2 is for nothing yeah
all he had to do was show up at a at a
wet bar
and the future falling none of that
matters no he's literally hitting on a
girl in
cancun and arnold walks up and kills
them and you're like well well that was
wasted yeah
i love how dave thinks he's like oh i
don't want to ruin the movie i'm like no
they did that to themselves yeah
you don't have any of them you're right
you are right that and it was in the
first ten like i'm done that's it i
don't know which one was the last one
before that but it's where they had to
decide that they were either going to uh
it would be required to inject arnold
with so many synthetic hormones that it
was just easier to cgi him
yeah yeah genesis yeah and he starts
going well we age just like uh
people yeah like no no they worked that
in yeah they worked better that's right
this was actually kind of fun in that
they remade that opening scene to the
first part yeah you should go outside
i liked it i liked the tie-in i was like
oh that's cool all right the rest of it
yeah you liked transformers for all
right i did not transfer one the point
is this we have to go to mug club we'll
be taking your chat because it's one of
those days uh our military
look
it doesn't it it's it's ceasing to be a
military okay
it's ceasing to be
what a military is designed to do and i
don't think that americans have the
stomach for what winning a war would
look like in afghanistan what the it's a
20-year war because we thought that we
could prop up a democracy right and that
same kind of idea is what permeates now
this inclusivity [ __ ] in the
military placing priorities on things
and values that do not matter that could
not be less relevant as it relates to
military engagement and combat
if your parents are lesbians who cares
one of them got into a fender bender and
climbed mount everest nobody gives a
rat's
ass nobody cares about any of these
things your race your gender your
ethnicity what you do on tick-tock none
of those things should matter it's how
effective are you at
killing destroying pillaring plundering
ending the confrontation as swiftly and
brutally as possible so that everyone
around says we better not even think of
trying them that is the only reason for
a military it should be the only reason
we go to war and it should be the only
it should be the criteria for the only
kind of people we include in a military
that's just one man's opinion you can
let me know what you think youtube i
know you don't like that so you can piss
off
bye